[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle I went to
hike panics on mountain in South Korea
with Tim and Dave and on the mountain we
explored an interesting temple
[Music]
[Music]
and to finish it off I had some iced
noodles which is a traditional Korean
dish
[Music]
all right we're here yes you can see you
there that is Guangzhou market now
Guangzhou market is really well known
for traditional kind of food and
clothing and souvenirs as well so let's
go and check it out
while this place is huge Wow they have
so many stuff here and fish
[Music]
all kinds of fruit
this is exciting
everything here is so interesting and
there's so many stuff I don't know where
to look
this is good
[Music]
these things look so good so good to go
maybe I should get some yeah I'm gonna
get some I'm gonna try it out and I'm
gonna tell you guys how it tastes
tasting so you get like sunflower you
get sesame seed and
you know
so it's peanut and it's walnut that is
mixed yeah really good I'm gonna get
some let's go check out the other stores
they also have some dried stuff dried
meat
Wow got some crab got some prawns some
more crabs little crabs and these are a
lot of interesting stuff very Korean
type of dishes hello hello people are
very friendly here and it's really nice
to be here
check out these crabs as well as our
more spicy and then you have normal ones
over here
[Music]
all right we in the food area there's
loads of food here that you can choose
from a lot of interesting stuff all
around me so this is something else here
I don't know what it is exactly take
this they boil it in there and then you
get that which is interesting right I
[Music]
have a lot of cool stuff here
whoa that is something now let's look it
up look at that
what is that
know what this is it's a word pudding
sausage that's a traditional Korean
sausage I've never seen that in my life
it looks pretty cool should I try it oh
this is also traditional Bakke rice cake
okay this tree just goes on forever it
doesn't stop play so when you come to
Korea
check out gwangjang market they also
have like this is this is kimbap
[Music]
so here you have the traditional kimbap
kind of food is really tasty and really
quick on the fat okay so it looks like
this all right Missy
[Music]
there's not bad it's pretty nice sauce
come tell me that let's try it with the
sauce
[Music]
it's budget I didn't expect it to be
spicy
people here are so friendly
[Music]
check this out
test times and stuff
not my kind of thing alright this is one
of the seven years shops they won a
souvenir from Korea seen so much now
what an interesting culture
[Music]
[Music]
Oh yo-yo good morning no not that day
here in Seoul I'm with max here and
today we're gonna check out Namsan tower
which is right in the center of Seoul
[Music]
all right so walking up it's a lot
steeper than it looks like in camera hi
do max on the way up we saw this little
guy
check out max compared to this car
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
so we're actually doing a bit of hiking
here Korea is actually very beautiful
[Music]
my family's clothes
how do you feel max exhilarated yeah get
this I got to go that way all right
[Music]
keep this Facebook Wow it's pretty cool
ah
we almost miss the tower we win this way
because we looked at this freaking wall
and was like wow
but the tower is behind us
all right we're here it is a lot bigger
when we're up close to it huh max my
goodness
let's not a porter over there all right
we're here
what world's first Olie tunnel let's
check it out
Oh
well look at this
Wow
feels like we're in space
check it out I'm gonna put in space look
look magazine space Wow
[Music]
this is pretty cool ah he's gone very
impressive this guy man you guessed it
right max is saying when we get here
this probably gonna do Starbucks okay
all right thank you all right man let's
do it all right so here the photos on
there playing some music to get us ready
you're that and then here they've got a
mirror for you so you can get yourself
ready for the photos and then I got a
green screen yeah that's our photo
oh yeah we made it to the top of the
tower
600 meters up pretty good
let me show you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh we're in the elevator
check it out
those are this myth all right
all right so we're done we saw an unsent
tower it was cool very beautiful
we're a little bit tired so we're in the
bus we're taking the easy way home yo
what up
we out you in South Korea and we're
gonna do some more videos today got
memory in the building while the section
Maria's building so we actually another
building is Daniel getting ready for the
setup hey guys Maria
[Music]
the lady of the moments so we're gonna
be more tips of how our modeling
lifestyle works and yeah because I came
for more videos she very graciously gave
us some iced lemon tea to step on hmm
thank you very much dlm statue
[Music]
so we're shooting today
with Maria again and today's model tips
about career your appearance what kind
of a girl you should have so stay tuned
how it looks like behind the scenes and
I have my brother Max he's behind me
what up guys I'm here behind the scenes
I'm the director today come on two
models here Maria and Daniel they're
gonna be sharing some tips of how to do
modeling more professional stage guys
brilliant oh that was close all right
all right all right all right yes
[Music]
we're download the video now we're
chilling and we're just going to the
park
so on this rocks you're supposed to take
off your shoes and just huh wow so
beautiful here I'm gonna try taking off
my shoes and let's see I can already
feel that I didn't think I'm made for
this let's try it
if you walk very soft now I can see
Maria's she's done this before so we're
at the river check this out
so beautiful here
[Music]
how'd you guys like this place is it
nice beautiful right
[Music]
now that's our is G Junction thumb jump
shield machine I cannot pronounce Korean
words I'm terrible at it
jeongsu okay okay you hurry I'm not
gonna try to keep the expert yeah now
they might not have noticed it but Maria
and Max drew very close to my heart
Korea is a lovely place isn't it very
very beautiful it doesn't feel like
Korea for me it was weird yeah yeah a
lot of people don't think Korea is this
pretty but check it out
another day is almost finished in Korea
it's a little bit sad you know because
every day is a gift
today's at his end but we did a video
today we had some great great lunch from
Maria Wow she's oh my goodness he's
making just food you guys need to check
out her Instagram it's so good and yeah
her YouTube channel as well because I'm
sure she's gonna have some recipes on
there I'm gonna start posting a lot of
recipes cooking and then we were done
with that we chill talked a little bit
about life you know and then we went to
the park well I'm gonna miss this place
yes
[Music]